[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ses idées qui gouvernent
le monde nous allons vous parler de la
reconquête industrielle la reconquête
industrielle est plus qu'un credo
politique ou une nécessité économique
c'est une urgence nationale urgence
d'agir pour conquérir une souveraineté
industrielle et une autonomie
stratégique pour le mois dans les
secteurs où la dépendance rime avec
impuissance urgence de se positionner en
europe face à l'allemagne où nous
accusons un retard notamment au niveau
des biens manufacturés comme du commerce
extérieur urgence par rapport aux états
unis et à la chine qui domine le marché
des technologies de l'innovation et des
biens ordinaires de consommation urgence
dans la décarbonation d énergie ou notre
avantage comparatif dans
l'électronucléaire doit trouver
rapidement un re déploiement industriel
et territoriales pour soutenir les
mobilités depuis les années 2000 de
nombreux plans industriel du nom de leur
auteur le plan jean louis beffa le plan
christian blanc le plan louis gallois le
dernier plan d'investissement france
2030 d'emmanuel macro également tous ces
plans ont été promulguées avec des
milliards d'euros à la clé avec des
résultats qui se font attendre la france
dispose de quelques uns tout dans
l'aéronautique l'espace l'industrie
d'armement des services aux
collectivités
le luxe le nucléaire ces fleurons
économiques dont nous allons parler sont
au coeur de la reconquête économique et
industriel mais pour ce faire il faudra
mobiliser de nombreux leviers dont la
recherche l'éducation scientifique
le capital risque et trouver de nouveaux
outils institutionnels les outils
également de gouvernance de ce vaste
programme nous allons vous entretenir
avec mes invités
madame agnès pannier rue nash et ancien
ministre chargé de l'industrie eric
trappier vous êtes président de dassault
aviation
stéphane israël vous êtes président
daria espace patrick daher vous êtes
président du groupe daher
[Musique]
madame panier rue rachel une question un
peu paradoxal que je vais vous poser la
france dispose d'individualités
brillantes dans l'ensemble des domaines
scientifiques et techniques mais le
résultat collectif n'est pas à la
hauteur des résultats industriels
comment vous expliquez cette distorsion
alors si vous parlez d industrialisation
je crois qu'il ya une raison très simple
c'est à dire que ce qui s'est passé
entre grosso modo le début des années 80
et 2015 2016 c'est le résultat d'une
perte de compétitivité de la france
d'une perte de compétitivité en matière
de coûts et ça ça me suffit de comparer
le coût de l'industrie française moi
j'ai été dans l'industrie automobile
et lorsque je faisais des cotations pour
des clients suivants jeu côté depuis une
usine française une usine polonaise où
une usine britannique
je n'avais pas les mêmes résultats et je
n'avais pas la même capacité à gagner
mes appels d'offres sur des produits ou
vous gagnez au centime près et vous
gagnez au centime près parce que le
consommateur dépense au centime près sur
ce type de biens de production donc ça
c'est très clairement le premier élément
c'est un élément qui billets à notre
système fiscal au social c'est à dire
que
je crois que la cour des comptes le dit
très bien les entreprises industrielles
encore aujourd'hui alors qu'on a baissé
les impôts de 26 milliards d'euros sous
ce quinquennat sont les plus taxés en
europe évidemment comparativement à
d'autres pays du monde mais c'est
également lié à un surcroît de
réglementation et là encore les chiffres
sont assez claires le world economic
forum nos classes au delà de la 90e
place en termes de simplicité
administrative et ce sont des surcoûts
redon tout cela pèse sur la
compétitivité de nos entreprises ce qui
ne veut pas dire que nous n'avons pas
des grands groupes portées par des
personnalités françaises au plan
international rayonne et fonctionne et
on voit bien que ce n'est pas une
question d'individualités mais que c'est
aussi une question de compétitivité du
site il s'agisse de fiscalité ou de
bureaucratie c'est à l'état de réagir
mais c'est tout à fait ce que vous avez
raison complètement c'est pour ça que
depuis 2010 est avec le président de la
république nous avons mené une politique
de réindustrialisation dont le premier
chapitre est de rendre le site france
plus compétitifs baisse de la fiscalité
lisibilité de la fiscalité un jeu je
pense à la baisse de la trajectoire de
l'impôt sur les sociétés où on dit dès
2017 nous serons à 25 % 25 % de
fiscalité sur les sociétés c'est plutôt
le haut de la fourchette européenne mais
au moins on donne un signal est en
baisse de 33 1/3 à 25% baisse des impôts
de production mais c'est également tout
ce que nous avons fait pour simplifier
accompagner les chefs d'entreprise dans
le plan de relance on parle beaucoup des
accompagnements financiers mais il ya
aussi tout l'accompagnement
administratif pour aider deux nouvelles
implantations soit d'investisseurs
étrangers soit d'investisseurs français
pour leur aider à monter leur dossier à
avoir des autorisations de construire à
avoir des autorisations
d'exploiter et ce n'est pas un hasard si
sous ce quinquennat nous avons recréé
l'emploi industriel en 2017 en 2018 en
2019 et même en 2021 ça n'était pas
arrivé depuis 2000 on va droit pour
l'occasion d'en parler alors sur la
distorsion entre les talents individuels
et le résultat collectif eric trappier
comment vous interpréter le fait que
nous n'arrivons pas à
coller si je puis dire au peloton de
tête écoutez je crois que dans
l'aéronautique non seulement on colle au
plan de trompette mais on est en tête ça
ses gains des grands paradoxes français
malgré la difficulté de différences de
compétitivités
l'aéronautique française aérospatiale
française se classe tout à fait en tête
du peloton elle favorise et si je prends
les années comme idée que je l'aimé un
peu de côté elle contribue à la balance
commerciale extérieure de manière
notable elle est à la pointe de
l'innovation elle va être à la pointe de
la transformation environnementales
elles embauchent elles embauchent des
talents al embauche des hommes des
femmes elle aimerait embaucher un peu
plus de femmes mais ça va venir et elle
est réussie
on est la réussite d'airbus c'est une
réussite on va rentrer dans le détail la
réussite du rafale c'est une réussite
face principalement des concurrents qui
sont américains avec une différence de
compétitivité qui se situe de l'ordre de
40% si on prend des chiffres très
comptable sur les impôts sur les charges
sociales etc malgré cette différence de
compétitivité l'industrie aéronautique
française s'impose dans le monde
stéphane israël est-ce que sincèrement
depuis 4 5 ans remonte la pente sur le
plan d'industrialisation
je pense que si on est objectif
on peut dire que il ya la prise de
conscience que vous évoquez depuis pas
mal d'années et vous avez évoqué ses
plans successifs et que le plan beffa
que j'avais oublié il ya eu un moment
important et d'ailleurs l'actuel
président de la république était quand
même un peu en charge déjà certains
égards avec le rapport gallois qui était
en 2013 où il ya eu cette volonté de
remettre l'industrie effectivement au
coeur des politiques économiques c'est à
ce moment là qu'on a décidé du crédit
impôt compétitivité emploi qui est une
mesure qui a duré et effectivement de
façon incontestable depuis 2010 est
cette mobilisation a très fortement
continuer donc voilà je pense que je ne
dirais pas que tout a commencé il ya
quelques années mais on peut évidemment
dire que pendant ce quinquennat y ait eu
des choses très importantes
il ya eu aussi et la ministre on n'a pas
encore parlé donc je me permets de le
dire une focale aussi un peu plus sur le
rôle des start up qui peut être avant
avait été moins vu le rapport gallois
était peut-être davantage tournés à
certains égards vers l'ensemble de
l'industrie des on parlait beaucoup des
filières donc et de ce point de vue là
c'est important parce que les grands
groupes doivent travailler avec les
startups il ya tous les projets de
france 2030 donc il ya une véritable
mobilisation c'est incontestable alors
patrick d'air on a entendu stéphane
israël arianespace grandes entreprises
dassault aviation grandes entreprises et
vous vous êtes à la jonction on va
rentrer dans le détail de votre activité
mais ce que vous avez été aidées pour
vous développer
alors
qu'il est de façon considérable il faut
bien voir qu'il ya eu un changement très
profond dans la philosophie économique
de la france la philosophie économique
de la france était de privilégier des
grands champions et nous avons des
grands champions la buse d'assaut
l'espace mais la philosophie économique
de la france n'était pas de privilégier
l'ensemble de la supply chain
industrielle et on a assisté depuis
depuis quelques années à un renversement
assez profond j'ai ensuite quelques
exemples premier exemple c'est pour moi
ce fut la création du fsi pourrait dire
ce que c'est le f 6 et le fonds dits
souverains le fond d'une intervention de
la france pour aider les entreprises
avec deux fils de deux objectifs après
l'objectif réindustrialiser la france
premier objectif réindustrialiser les
territoires français et le deuxième
objectif permettre à des pme sûr que
nous étions de devenir des outils et de
devenir elle-même des
apprentis champions de l'industrie
française et ça a été fait quand le fsi
est rentré dans notre capital
nous faisions 300 millions de chiffre
d'affaires et aux enfants une aire deux
en dix ans donc ça a été une très grande
intrigue modifications deuxième exemple
qui est quand même très important c'est
cette cette génération d'entreprises qui
commençait à avoir une maturité maturité
dans l'innovation maturité industrielle
aurait pu disparaître dans la clusaz du
coc vide l'accusent de coville a été je
suis pendant qu'on parle d'en parler de
l'aéronautique vraiment très très
difficile et là l'état est venus à notre
aide l'état et l'ensemble de la filière
à vrai dire alors on va parler justement
de sa malle un panier ménager le plan
france 2030 c'est 30 milliards oui mais
si on prend la crise du coc vide c'est
200 milliards d' épargne
à côté de ça les profits du cac 40 sont
également très élevé est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas orienter cette manne
financière vers la réindustrialisation
alors d'abord on a tendance à comparer
des chiffres qui ne sont pas comparables
vous avez raison de mentionner les
entreprises du cac 40 les entreprises du
cac 40 en moyenne c'est pas vrai de
toutes les entreprises mais en moyenne
réalise 15% de leur activité sur le
territoire français et en moyenne leur
actionnariat français pèse 15 % c'est à
dire que ce sont des entreprises
extraordinairement internationale et qui
ne représente pas la réalité du tissu
français là où elles sont importantes
c'est qu'elle joue un rôle de leader et
qu'elles peuvent tirer un écosystème de
pme et d'entreprises de taille
intermédiaire et qu'elles ne font plus
facilement dans l'endroit elles ont leur
siège par proximité culturelle pour les
révisions une précision vous êtes en
train de dire que les entreprises du cac
du fait que leur actionnariat
français n'est que de 15 à 20% les
profits qui se dégage ne concerne que 15
à 20% des noms c'est leur empreinte
industriels et leurs empreintes
territoriale l'endroit où elles génèrent
des profits en règle générale est plus
réduit en france que dans d'autres pays
suffit de regarder la génération de
profits au plan mondial d'une entreprise
classique du cac 40 vous avez un marché
en croissance souvent qui a été la chine
qui l'a être un petit peu plus en
difficulté en ce moment vous avez un
marché américain qui a été assez porteur
vous avez de nouvelles géographies comme
le brésil et donc réduire l'économie
française aux entreprises du cac 40
c'est faire une erreur méthodologique et
je pense que patrick daher le dit très
bien ce qui est très important aussi
c'est de regarder la réalité de
l'emprunter industrielle de chaque
entreprise les pme pour l'essentiel
fabrique en france les entreprises de
taille intermédiaire ou un gros socle en
france et des usines pivot qui peuvent
être dans d'autres pays d'europe sur une
géographie des amériques sud ou nord sur
une géographie
des de l'asie et lorsqu'on parle
d'emplois industriels français forcément
on va parler de ce qui se passe en
france donc on n'a pas forcément une
réalité totale entre le nom d'une
entreprise qui est française et son
empreinte industrielle française par
contre ce qu'on sait c'est pour ça que
c'est utile d'avoir des grandes
entreprises c'est que par proximité
culturelle une entreprise française une
grande entreprise française peut-être
donner plus de travail à une pme une
entreprise de taille intermédiaire
qu'elle ne le ferait si elles étaient
allemandes ou américaines c'est pour ça
qu'il faut être un peu on vous a écouté
là dessus mais sur l'épargné est ce qui
pourrait pas y avoir des mesures
fiscales importantes pour drainer cette
épargne populaire vers la
réindustrialisation alors pourquoi
drainer vers la réindustrialisation la
première chose c'est probablement de la
drainer vers
l'investissement risque c'est à dire
l'investissement dans les entreprises
pas l'investissement dans les
obligations dans les fonds monétaires
c'est-à-dire ce qui au fond rapporte un
petit peu d'argent et très sécurisé et
on comprend pourquoi les épargnants au
fond un petit peu attention parce que
c'est leur argent ils n'ont pas envie de
perdre de l'argent mais ce qui ce dont
ont besoin aujourd'hui les entreprises
françaises et souvent les pme les
entreprises de taille intermédiaire ces
deux fonds propres c'est à dire
d'actionnaires et s'est pas complètement
dans la culture française
de développer l'actionnariat français
est là on peut le faire avec
l'actionnariat salarié avec la loi pacte
on a facilité le fait que lorsque vous
êtes salarié d'une entreprise on
facilite l'accès au capital de
l'entreprise ça peut être fait avec les
placements d'assurance vie en favorisant
l'investissement vers les actions plus
de bois perché investissements à 10
personnes
nous avons maintenant une nouvelle
premier ministre madame bornes est-ce
que vous considériez que la
réindustrialisation fait partie des
priorités nationales oui mais très
clairement pourquoi parce que la
réindustrialisation
c'est la réponse à trois choses la
fracture territoriale
si vous regardez la carte de la
désindustrialisation
c'est la carte de la montée des extrêmes
c'est la carte de l'abstentionnisme
c'est la carte aussi de la perte de
richesse sur des territoires et de
l'abandon de certains territoires
deuxième chose parce que c'est une
réponse à la question du pouvoir d'achat
aujourd'hui on le voit dans les hauts de
france dans les hautes france un emploi
industriel paye 25 % de plus qu'un
emploi qui n'est pas industriel et ça au
moment où chacun se préoccupe de son
pouvoir d'achat c'est quelque chose qui
fait la différence et je vous parle de
gens qui ont une formation
professionnelle qui peuvent être ouvrier
par exemple et puis la troisième chose
c'est que nous sommes face à un défi
considérable qui est la transition
énergétique et écologique et où va se
faire cette transition dans l'industrie
c'est dans l'industrie qu'on va être
capable de mettre au point le moteur des
carbonnais est de faire en sorte qu'ils
soient accessibles au plus grand nombre
c'est dans l'industrie qu'on va être
capable de faire des matériaux de
construction qui permettent d'économiser
de la chaleur ou d'être plus frais en
été donc ce sont là que tout va se
développer à voir une souveraineté une
capacité à la fois d'innovation mais
également de production sur le
territoire français et européen est clé
si on veut maîtriser ça prend vous en
rien dû alors je voudrais avoir l'avis
de vous messieurs les industriels sur la
question de l'emploi est ce que le taux
d'emploi le taux d'employabilité
notamment dans les professions
qualifiées est inférieure en france à la
moyenne de l'oscd e s que vous avez du
mal à recruter dans ce domaine à
monsieur à prier si israël aujourd'hui
on on conserve un taux de chômage
relativement important même si on l'a vu
ces deux trois dernières années le taux
d'emploi augmente et on a dans
l'industrie je parle pas de
l'aéronautique je parle de l'industrie
en général toujours des difficultés à
embaucher à haut niveau des ingénieurs
jusqu'au compagnons et les ouvriers en
passant par les techniciens et là on a
un gros travail à faire sur la formation
et la préparation à l'industrie de tous
ses métiers et il faut qu'on est con
continue à poursuivre on le fait au sein
de lui-même qui le l'union des dead et
des entreprises de métallurgie à
promouvoir les métiers dans l'industrie
pour les orienter les jeunes vers
l'industrie et là on a un travail avec
l'éducation nationale qu'on a mené avec
le ministère de l'industrie et
l'éducation nationale pour arriver à
mobiliser les forces vives de la nation
c'est à dire les jeunes vers ces métiers
parce que on leur offre dans l'industrie
une solution de travail et on l'a vu à
transition énergétique ce qui est très
important mais poursuivre travailler sur
les produits lancé une fusée ariane
faire voler un airbus décarbonés demain
mais en partie avec des fuels alternatif
faire voler un avion de combat et
contribuer à la défense du pays ça vous
a pas échappé qu'il ya un contexte
stratégique majeure je pense qu'il faut
orienter et travailler dans l'énergie
parce que sans énergie a pas d'industrie
et d'industrie c'est la transformation
de la matière à partir de l'énergie vers
des produits ou là l'innovation a pu se
matérialiser donc il est fondamental de
dire à nos jeunes venaient dans
l'industrie venez faire de l'industrie
plutôt que de stigmatiser comme certains
le font au contraire les solutions sont
dans l'industrie et la france a toujours
été au sommet de la capacité à
développer des produits industriels de
haut niveau il ya des problématiques de
compétitivité on a commencé à avoir des
réponses de la part de l'état avec par
exemple la baisse des impôts de
production dont on a parlé on peut aussi
dans le cadre d'un dialogue social ceci
aussi dans l'industrie qui est un
dialogue social c'est aussi là que les
gens on va avoir un travail est en
territoire parce que comme l'a dit
patrick les grands leaders et c'est un
paradoxe dassault n'est pas du tout à
une société du cac40 parce qu'elle ne
l'est pas et elle à 90% de son emploi en
france elle a des sous traitants
principalement en france en territoire
qu'elle connaît des grands groupes comme
celui de patrick d'air mais aussi des
pme multitude de pme qui sont implantées
dans les territoires et on le voit bien
que c'est là la clé c'est d'être capable
d'avoir les grands groupes qui financent
autofinance une partie de leurs
technologies de temps en temps avec
l'aide de l'état dans les plans mais
méfions-nous aussi des plantes c'est
derrick faut aussi laisser à l'industrie
la capacité de se mobiliser c'est une
aide et tant mieux mais ce n'est pas on
ne doit pas tout à l'état en termes
d'innovation il faut que l'industrie se
mobilisent et derrière l'emploi va être
là c'est des bons salaires dans
l'industrie contrairement à ce qu'on
croit et donc c'est une paix sociale
aussi si l'emploi est là et si les gens
peuvent se réaliser
non pour redonner aussi le l'envi pour
les jeunes d'être dans l'industrie est
la fierté de faire des produits
matériels qui vont être utiles à la
collectivité et stéphane israël sur la
question de l'emploi vous avez du mal à
trouver
j'allais dire chaussure à votre pied
c'est à dire des emplois qualifiés et à
quoi vous attribuer ce ce taux
d'employabilité
inférieure en france à celui à ce qu'il
est dans l' ocde en sueur sur l'emploi
je pense que les industries
aéronautiques et spatiales bénéficie
quand même de la réussite de la filière
donc eric trappier ou patrick daher ne
l'ont pas dit parce qu'ils sont modestes
mais il faut quand même prendre en
compte le fait que les succès de nos
groupes et de la filière font que quand
on est un jeune ingénieur aujourd'hui on
a plutôt tendance à privilégier
l'aéronautique et le spatial à d'autres
filières donc nous on a au sein du monde
industriel une chance qui est notre rôle
de leader et des succès construit par la
france depuis des décennies dans ce
secteur et donc c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on a enfin très
honnêtement deux d'excellents ingénieurs
dans l'ensemble de nos bureaux d'études
ou de nos usines
après je pense qu'on
on rencontre tous chez les plus jeunes
un peu de bougeotte donc je sais pas si
vous l'observez dans dans vos groupes
mais on voit qu'il ya des volontés
parfois de s'inscrire dans des projets
plus court nous on est sur des projets
très long ariane 6 c'est plusieurs
années de développement un grand avion
ses plus grandes plusieurs années de
développement et les jeunes parfois dans
cette culture du digital souhaite que
les résultats arrivent plus vite et donc
il faut les retenir parce que les
compétences que l'on a construite on a
besoin de les conserver donc on observe
on observe cela on est en ile-de-france
en tous les cas un peu propres ailes au
plein emploi donc il ya un peu de
tension mais
la réussite entraîne aussi l'excellence
donc secteur de ce point de vue là est
attractif je serai derrière votre
impression est ce que vous pensez qu'une
femme premier ministre première ministre
qui est polytechnicienne ça va donner
allez dire une bouffée d'air à la
culture scientifique
fait que madame bornes et une expérience
dans la grande entreprise une expérience
dans
beaucoup de domaines qui nous sont très
proches sera très certainement un
facteur dynamisant je veux citer un
élément dans par rapport à votre
question tout à l'heure qui est pourquoi
est ce que nous avons des manques quand
voulant embaucher
les gens que nous embauchons sont d'une
manière générale très qualifiés la main
de française est très qualifié quand on
regarde ce qui se passe dans d'autres
pays du monde dans lesquels nous
travaillons tous que ce soit des pays
européens au plus loin nous avons une
main d'oeuvre qui est très qualifiés
dans tous les domaines et suffisante en
nombre à la voilà c'est cesser la
question suffisante en nombre et là je
pense que nous souffrons d'un défaut de
la france de la dyade vieille dame un
ministre qui a été de dire je privilégie
les filières universitaires ou les
filières d'enseignement d'excellence et
nous n'avons pas privilégiée nous
français
l'apprentissage là les contrats
d'alternance c'est à dire mettre nos
jeunes sur le terrain pour qu'ils voient
que l'industrie et bien finalement
l'industrie s'est pas aulas l'industrie
c'est beau l'industrie c'est un élément
de fierté nous n'avons pas fait ça a
beaucoup changé si vous avez remarqué en
nombre d'emplois dans le monde de
l'alternance et de l'apprentissage dans
les quelques dernières années donc fort
à faire on a encore beaucoup de progrès
à faire mais je pense que ça a été un
des éléments
un deuxième en café que nous n'ont pas
suffisamment de gens n'ont pas formé
mais de gens intéressés par le monde de
l'industrie on vous a entendu
[Musique]
stéphane israël je voudrais vous poser
cette question en france est ce qu'il y
à un steve jobs soit un jeff bezos ce
qu'est ce que c'est que cette passion
brûlante dans évoqué par steve jobbs est
ce que quand on est dans ces métiers là
l'espace on a cette passion brûlante
est-ce que vous avez vous sentez que
vous êtes en train de propulser une
industrie d'avenir quelque chose qui
fait à la fois rêver et qui transcendent
le progrès en quelque chose de
formidable oui je crois que cette
passion brûlante on la ressent tous dans
nos métiers les ingénieurs en général
sont sont des passionnés quel que soit
le secteur mais voilà les qui vole
il ya un petit plus peut-être un bon
voilà et donc à cette l'éternité jeu
ouais ya peut-être un rapport comme ça
ce qui va un peu au-delà nous mêmes mais
ce soit des avions des hélicoptères des
fusées il ya cette passion brûlante et
je peux vous dire que ça compte beaucoup
la motivation de nos équipes parce que
les projets sont difficiles et que les
équipes vraiment donne tout alors après
la question c'est toujours celle des
entrepreneurs des créateurs d'entreprise
c'est vrai qu'aux états unis ces
dernières années dans le monde du
digital il s'est produit des choses qui
ne sont pas forcément
arriver en europe les écosystèmes ne
sont pas ne sont pas les mêmes aux états
unis il ya un mélange d'une très forte
commande publique et ça je crois qu'il
faut qu'on en prenne conscience en
france en france on pense beaucoup
parfois qu'il faut être actionnaire pour
avoir du poids en réalité si l'état veut
avoir de l' influence il faut qu'il soit
un client parce que quand vous êtes un
client je peux vous dire pour une
entreprise c'est très important et aux
états unis et à travers la défense
l'état est un énorme clients
après vous avez tous les écosystèmes de
la silicon valley et vous avez quelques
personnalités qui se détache et on vous
les avez cité donc en europe je dirais
il faut malgré tout continuer de jouer
sur ses atouts on a des très belles
boîtes qui sont des grandes boîtes ou
des boîtes intermédiaire et je crois que
ce serait une très grande erreur de les
délaisser on a besoin de ses succès et
puis si on peut aussi faire émerger de
nouveaux acteurs c'est très bien c'est
l'ambition de france 2030 qui est une
ambition non pas contre les grandes
boîtes mais avec les grandes entreprises
de favoriser aussi de nouveaux acteurs
et donc pourquoi pas oui d'aidé steve
blog ou jeff bezos français jeff bezos
j'ai beaucoup de sympathie pour lui
parce qu'il ya un client d'un on va en
parler en paris des îles et
particulièrement à l'honneur eric
trappier cette passion brûlante elle est
dans l'aviation mais le groupe dassault
c'est beaucoup de choses
c'est des avions qui font rêver alors
vont participer vous avez donné
naissance à falcon à l'avion militaire
le rafale bon c'est une industrie qui
fonctionne bien et qui est qu'ils nous
rapportent sur le plan du commerce
extérieur et sur le plan des
technologies innovatrices est ce que ce
succès industriel est appelée à durer
vous pensez que ça
une entreprise l'avenir nous appartient
sur le plan aéronautique
quand même bon faut rester modeste donc
il faut toujours avoir un oeil devant
soi pour pas trébucher et avoir un oeil
sur l'horizon pour savoir à peu près où
on veut aller donc en tout cas un chef
d'entreprise ce doit gérer sa maison au
jour le jour et de la préparer aux défis
du futur
on préserve chez dassault et dans
l'aéronautique en général la part de
rêve je sais que ça traumatise certains
nous nous encourageons les gens à
continuer à rêver le génie de
l'aéronautique c'est de dire qu'on peut
faire voler un avion c'est le rêve
d'icare alors il faut faire attention
faut aussi être modeste on fait un peu
de philosophie il faut pas se brûler les
ailes donc il faut être sérieux parce
que je rappelle quand même qu'un avion
qui vole en général ils transportent des
passagers c'est un avion civil où ils
transportent un pilote militaire et donc
la sécurité doit être là donc c'est un
métier très sérieux la grande différence
qu'il ya entre les métiers du numérique
et métiers indus riel au sens des
produits s'est plue continuons-nous à
maîtriser les technologies qui
permettent de faire les produits et
d'ailleurs on associe le numérique
puisque le numérique c'est comment le
rêve va se matérialiser dans une
simulation qui nous permet d'aller
au-delà des capacités même de ce qu'on
sait faire aujourd'hui d'un point de vue
réelles et on va rendre le rêve rêves et
donc on va être capable grâce à ces
simulations de pouvoir se projeter dans
l'avenir et de dire voilà ce que sera
demain le transport aérien reste alors
pour l'instant de combat du futur en
réseau etc entend mener pour le civil on
à airbus pour le militaire ya rafale est
ce que vous vous préparez j'allais dire
une lune est ce que finalement on sera
compétitif dans vingt ans dans 50 ans
écoutez on a tellement entendu pendant
des années que on n'arrivait pas à
exporter le rafale maintenant on dit
c'est l'avion pas cher qui fait ou qui
est vraiment beaucoup plus capable que
ce que font les américains je rappelle
que les américains avec une différence
de compétitivité de 30 40 % avec un
nombre d'avions extraordinaire à f 16 ou
f 35c produits pour le marché domestique
à des milliers d'exemplaires quand on en
est à 100 150
on a réussi ce pari être compétitif si
vous voulez dire que les séries ne joue
pas sur la compétence mais malgré cet
effet de serre y négatif en ce qui nous
concerne mais ça n'a rien à faire c'est
à dire qu'au jour david o un rafale
savons un f-15 et c'est mieux ça vaut
mieux reste 15 h 35 c'est différent
parce que ça fait tout dans une taille
très réduite donc c'est là pourtant
j'essaie d'avoir un nouveau chasseur
européen parce qu'un jour viendra il
faudra bien prévoir le futur c'est à
dire que raphaël va être opérationnel on
va être encore produit pendant 10 15 ans
voire 20 ans il va rester opérationnels
encore 30 ans il ya cinquante vie aux
rafales de vent nous mais un jour
viendra il faudra bien prévoir quelque
chose donc on s'y met longtemps à
l'avant ce parce que les technologies a
développé ou à préparer son quelque
chose qui sont en amont donc c'est ça
qu'on est en train de faire on le fait
aussi pour les falcons c'est à dire que
les falcons c'est pas tout à fait
l'aviation commerciale c'est plus petit
ça doit se poser sur des toutes petites
pis ça doit être capable d'un certain
nombre de caractéristiques qui sont
différentes de l'avion commercial et
c'est très développée par exemple aux
états unis mais aussi ça se développe de
plus en plus en europe il faut prévoir
les futurs avions qui sont un falcon
c'est quoi c'est un bureau volant vous
êtes capable à bord de dormir de vous
restaurer de continuer à travailler donc
c'est l'internet c'est des satellites
super malin manière une ag sevani sera
elle en a parlé
trapier en a parlé est ce que la
commande publique elle est suffisante
aujourd'hui concernant
le domaine de l'aéronautique
alors d'abord elle est essentielle
pour structurer des filières et en
particulier à un moment on va devoir
transformer le contenu technologique de
ces filières eric trappier mentionné
l'avion qui doit venir derrière le
rafale c'est aujourd'hui qu'on va
commencer à le concevoir on assure la
partie spatiale une révolution avec
du côté à la fois des lanceurs l'émir
lanceurs des constellations de
satellites en orbite basse orbite haute
donc on a vraiment des mouvements qui se
font qu'ils doivent être accompagnés et
qui mieux que l'étape porter cette
vision de long terme par la commande
publique et permettre d'accompagner ces
entreprises ça c'est très clair on le
fait à la mesure de nos moyens c'est à
dire je pense que on l'a vu pendant le
la difficulté du coc vide on s'est
beaucoup appuyé sur la commande
militaire pour
faciliter ce passage très difficile de
la crise de l'aco vide qui avait
effondré l'industrie aéronautique et
florence parly la mise des armées a
vraiment joué son rôle de support de
soutien pour permettre aux entreprises
de sortir par le haut on a une question
européenne parce que si on compare les
moyens de la france avec ceux aux
hasards de la chine ou des états unis où
faut pas tout à fait dans la même
catégorie donc la question européenne
appelle effectivement avoir une
politique de défense urbaine sur lequel
le président la république a fait des
avancées notables récemment et c'est
vrai que dans la commande publique
si on pouvait s'appuyer sur ça on
pourrait avoir une force complémentaire
permettant de sortir par le haut on peut
d'ailleurs s'interroger je me joins dire
le loupé d'un vol spatial financé par la
commande publique américaine les deux à
trois fois celui d'un vol commercial là
on a vraiment une politique de deux je
dirais distorsions de concurrence d'une
certaine manière ou en tout cas de choix
politiques qui est pas forcément à notre
portée d'un point de vue budgétaire mais
il faut le savoir que ça existait donc
il faut trouver des voies et moyens
d'accompagner on commande publique tout
en étant comptable de nos équilibres
financiers on a un certain nombre
d'équipements et justement sur ce sujet
stéphanie serait
ariane 5 a fait son temps à rien 6 est
pour bientôt mais il ya quelques retards
quelques déboires ils sont dus à la
guerre en ukraine vous n'avez pas pu
utiliser soyouz mais ariane 6 va venir
on avait même annoncé qu'il y aurait un
contrat du siècle que vous avez signé
avec jeff bezos ce et amazon et d'ici
2026 et près de 600 satellites que la
france va lancer
vous voilà en concurrence avec la chine
les etats unis comme opérateur de
systèmes de lancement quels sont les
développements futurs donc pour vous
hier un peu comment tout ça va se passer
qu'est ce que vous attendez concrètement
pour que les pouvoirs publics
vous soutiennent et propulse finalement
c'est l'industrie qui est une industrie
d'avenir incontestablement oui alors
d'abord on va commencer rapidement par
ariane 5 est maintenant fin de vie
encore 5 ariane 5 à faire et puis elle a
vécu un moment extrêmement exceptionnel
le 25 décembre 2021 elle a embarqué dans
le cadre d'une coopération avec les
états unis le projet spatial le plus
ambitieux jamais lancé par les
américains un télescope qui s'appelle
james webb il a été lancé par ariane 5
il a eu une telle précision qu'on a
doublé l'espérance de vie de cet objet
qui coûte assez cher donc en fait le
voir les du satellite du le télescope et
nos télescopes t à un endroit qui
étaient quarante fois plus précis que ce
qui devait être et du coup on a il avait
besoin de moins de carburant pour se
propulser vers là où ils devaient aller
du coup il a doublé son expérience du
alors ariane 6 arrive et effectivement
ce dont a besoin réel si c'est
exactement ce qui a été évoqué par agnès
pannier-runacher et c'est en fait
d'avoir un soutien par la puissance
publique qui nous permet de mieux match
et comme on dit en mauvais français la
compétition américaine parce
qu'effectivement le modèle américain les
missions institutionnelles sont à la
fois beaucoup plus nombreuses et très
fortement payer et donc le compétiteur
d'ariane musk et de falcon va vendre un
peu près 100 ce qui vont clients
américains et va vendre 40 à 50 qui vend
sur le marché nous on a besoin d'avoir
un très fort engagement public à travers
des missions institutionnelles à travers
une couverture de nos coûts fixes pour
pouvoir être compétitif à l'export et la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'elle est et 2021
et la france c'est le ministre bruno le
maire qui s'en est occupé à jouer un
rôle très important
on a convaincu nos partenaires européens
d'adopter ce qu'on appelle dans notre
jargon une résolution de l'agencé
spatiale européenne qui organise ce
soutien public et quand on vend à amazon
et quand on vend 18 fusée amazon on a
pris en compte cette décision et puis
après il ya la préparation de la
prochaine génération qui volera plus tôt
en 2013 quand c'est toute la question de
la réutilisation on n'avait pas besoin
de lanceurs réutilisables donc on avait
des petits volumes et ça a été la loi de
l'espace pendant des années et là avec
l'explosion de leur big bass ya de plus
en plus de lancement à faire et ce
qu'ils avaient peu de sens quand il
fallait faire cinq à six lancements par
an a du sens quand il faut en faire
quinze ou vingt donc c'est le
réutilisables il ya là aussi une
dynamique était très poussés par un
gouvernement à travers un lanceur qui
s'appelle maya qui sera une petite fusée
réutilisables et l'intérêt ça sera
d'avoir un marché mais surtout
d'apprendre la réutilisation pour la
prochaine génération et donc ce que je
veux dire c'est la stratégie du marché
sur ses deux jambes il faut soutenir la
génération qui arrive et il faut
encourager des technologies plus
distribué et c'est ce qui a été fait
donc je m'en félicite et je le dis en
tout en toute neutralité parce que joue
pas là pour décerner des bons points
pour nous ce qui aurait été horrible
c'est qu'on délaisse ariane 6 pour se
précipiter dans la prochaine génération
parce que là on était mort parce que si
on n'avait pas rien si je peux vous
assurer qu'il n'y a pas eu quelque chose
qui aurait volé en 2030 en revanche
qu'on ait trouvé un équilibre entre un
engagement très fort pour ariane 6 et
une volonté d'encourager des
technologies plus destructif ça nous va
très bien dit il se dit que vous êtes
soutenus par l'état français mais
mollement par bruxelles et le
commissaire thierry breton c'est vrai ou
c'est du nom alors je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas qui dit ça en tout cas ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que le
commissaire thierry breton pousse un
projet de constellation européenne qui
pour nous est très important et on
souhaite les concurrents avec ce que
vous faites là non pas du temps et
complémentaires il ya de la place nous
plus on a de clients mieux on se porte
et donc si une grande constellation
européenne et je peux vous dire qu'on a
beaucoup poussé pour qu'elle existe et
qu'on en a parlé il ya plusieurs années
donc nous on attend qu'il ce que ce
projet se matérialise est effectivement
en ce moment nous sommes en discussion
autour du lancement de satellites
galileo et copernicus le commissaire
breton a dit qu'il souhaitait passer un
engagement de plusieurs lancements c'est
exactement ce que fait l'armée
américaine elle achète 20 à 30 lancement
d'un coup là ça sera dénombre un peu
moindre donc on est dans cette dans
cette discussion
donc nous sommes aussi soutenu par
bruxelles merci patrick daher là une
question importante à vous poser
dans le différentiel c'est à dire la
différence entre le commerce extérieur
de la france et l'allemagne ont dit que
l'allemagne est plus apte à
fournir des produits manufacturés parce
qu'elle a des pme très importante ce que
vous avez appelé dès jeudi donc c'est à
dire ce qui est derrière en fin de
compte c'est à dire la grosse pme
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire en france
pour développer ce chaînon industrielle
où vous avez réussi personnellement mais
manifestement et nous n'avons pas ce
tissu industriel de grosses pme je crois
que c'est l analyse et un un peu fausse
nouvelle date un peu
nous n'avions pas ce tissu industriel
des grosses pme où il est il était très
faible
j'ai parlé de la dfs il est aussi et
depuis intégré dans la bpi qui est la
banque publique d'investissement depuis
cette époque là on a eu une approche
différente maison la france a une
approche différente en disant comment
est ce que je peux
favoriser la croissance de pme voulait
transformer en hôtel et ya eu aussi une
approche fiscale en même temps qui a été
de dire comment est ce que je peux aider
à la transmission à la génération
suivante des pme vers vers la génération
suivante les deux ont une dizaine
d'années maintenant une quinzaine
d'années d'existence et la france
progressivement est en train de créer
des outils de taille importante qui
deviennent même des champions un peu
dans tous les domaines et un peu dans
toutes les régions ce qu'il faut voir
c'est que quand il ya quelques années on
parlait de l'éthique avait réussi dans
une région on parlait de l'outil une
aujourd'hui dans toutes les régions vous
avez 10 15 20 utile donc le phénomène
est enclenché on peut pas dire que l'on
peut pas dire que ça n'existe pas le
phénomène est vraiment bien enclenché il
faut le favori si il ya les moyens de
favoriser et si je reviens dans le monde
de l'aéronautique
un des moyens puisque vous parlez de la
d'innovation un des moyens a été ce que
nous appelons nous c'est l'organisme de
recherche de l'aviation civile nous
appelons le corac le corac à était sous
la tutelle de la dgse
du gouvernement d'abord pardon à la
famille mais de la dgs et le corac a
entraîné ce temps
un organisme de recherche
multi entreprise a entraîné derrière lui
les efforts de recherche de toutes les
pme eti c'est à dire qu'au lieu de se
disperser chacun de notre côté nous
avons concentrés nous sommes en train de
concentrer nos efforts pour travailler
ensemble a en fait à l'avion décarbonés
à l'avion du futur et ça ce genre de
travaux vont faire de jeu si ma
conviction profonde en tout cas vont
faire de la de la france de notre
filière aéronautique en france vont
faire de cette filière des futurs
champions au niveau
européen d'un entendu et mondiale aussi
haut gradé daher qui vont pousser qui
vont émerger il y en a déjà
[Musique]
mal en panne hier une ag on parle de
réindustrialisation la dernière campagne
électorale qui a vu la réélection des
manuels macro à l'elysée a été subie il
ya pas dominé mais on a beaucoup parlé
du pouvoir d'achat des bas salaires des
inégalités territoriales
à votre avis est-ce que la
réindustrialisation qui vous tient à
coeur est synonyme de prospérité
recouvrait de de lutter contre ces
inégalités sociales c'est à dire que si
on ré industrialise est ce que le pays à
mieux tout à fait il suffit de regarder
comment ces dernières années
depuis 2000 le revenu par tête a
décroché en france par rapport à
l'allemagne qui a réussi à préserver le
poids de son industrie dans son économie
globale et c'est ce que je vous
indiquais tout à l'heure c'est à dire
que dans l'industrie on a la capacité à
mettre des emplois dans des zones
périphériques et rurale parce qu'on
règle générale on ne construit pas une
usine au mulliez d'une grande ville
quinze emplois industriels créer 3 4
parfois cinq emplois autour du site
industriel du service directement aux
sites industriels mais ça va être le
petit café du point où le petit
commerçant du coin et c'est aussi
l'emploi public puisque c'est la classe
additionnels dans l'école du village
pour accueillir les enfants du personnel
et puis l'industrie paye plutôt mieux
donc tire les revenus vers le haut alors
il faut savoir que ce qu'on a fait ces
dernières années ont permis d'arrêter la
saigné industrielle est encore très
fragile moi je je regarde ça avec
beaucoup de lucidité c'est à dire que il
ya un vrai changement depuis cinq ans
six ans mais objectivement c'est encore
très fragile et dans le conte
l'environnement concurrentiel dans
lequel on est il va falloir continuer si
on veut effectivement agir sur le long
terme pour le pouvoir d'achat c'est à
dire en ré industrialiser en permettant
à décide de s'installer en restant
compétitifs en formant les jeunes et en
rendant plus attractifs les métiers de
l'industrie parce que c'est une chaîne
complète c'est un plan d'action complet
qu'il nous faut pour poursuivre cet
effort ce qui est intéressant c'est que
c'est pas perdu aujourd'hui suivant les
critères on est entre 10 et 12%
d'industrie dans notre économie
l'allemagne est à 13% vous avez est à 23
% quasiment le double par nous
évidemment 3% beaucoup plus vous avez
des études une étude récente qui est
sorti par exemple de
pricewaterhousecoopers qui indique que
avec 2 serait ce que le seul plan france
2030 on est capable d'aller chercher
deux
3.2.1 industrielle en plus dans notre
économie donc ça c'est intéressant et ça
veut dire qu'on a les leviers en main
parce que on y boit en ingénierie parce
qu'on a des talents parce qu'on est bien
engagée dans la transition écologique et
parce qu'il ya des moyens publics pour
réindustrialiser le pays mais encore une
fois c'est extraordinairement fragile il
faut être très vigilant à
comment dire conserver cette
compétitivité du site france voir aller
plus loin investir dans l'innovation
parce que c'est un point clé et investir
dans les compétences vous lisiez au
début compétences scientifiques les
compétences techniques elles sont
essentielles et les métiers manuels
parce que vous avez une virtuosité du
geste maintenant entendu là-dessus alors
eric trappier je voudrais vous poser
cette question vous avez dit que le
rafale ou ce que fait la france en
matière d'aviation civile et militaire
eux n'a rien à envier à nos concurrents
qu'ils soient américains ou chinois
alors si ça n'a rien à voir on a quand
même délocalisé est ce qu'à votre avis
est-ce que si on veut ré industrialiser
il faut relocaliser où c'est un thème
intellectuelle à écouter je crois qu'il
ya un peu des deux c'est à dire que 1 on
a la chance dans l'aéronautique de
partager à la fois l'aéronautique et la
défense les grands groupes sont tous
impliqués dans l'aéronautique et la
défense et donc qu'ils ont ancré leur
stock d'emplois en territoire en france
donc le denier public qui contribue à la
défense et dieu sait qu'aujourd'hui on
voit qu'il est important d'investir dans
l'industrie de défense ce que certains
voudraient est contestée je parle de les
problématiques de taxonomie européenne
je trouve qu'on devrait avoir des
médailles quand on investit dans la
défense puisque ça contribue à la
défense du pays mais en plus ça
contribue à l'emploi de haut niveau et à
l'emploi en territoire de tous les
niveaux pour être capable d'alimenter
ceci donc dans l'aéronautique vous allez
voir les grands groupes que ce soit
airbus thales safran dassault les grands
deux pays et les pme elles ont leur
emploi en france là où c'est beaucoup
plus difficile c'est par exemple
l'automobile vous avez sur l'automobile
est ce qui est peut-être pas le thème
aujourd'hui mais je vois les deux mois
et je peux comparer sur l'automobile on
a devant nous une crise majeure qui
s'amorce une crise de l'emploi parce que
la transition énergétique
le passage d'un type de voiture un autre
petit de voiture va laisser de côté non
pas les grands groupes mais un certain
nombre de pme installée en territoire
qui peuvent s'inquiéter de leur futur
est là est un challenge extraordinaire
sur lesquels il va falloir qu'on
s'appuie avec l'état pour essayer de
transformer ses anciennes pme qui
travaillent sur des moteurs
conventionnels dans cette nouvelle
technologie ces nouvelles technologies
et je dois dire pour finir que ce qui
contribue fortement la réussite et à la
relocalisation ma femme d'entreprise
c'est aussi le numérique nous nous
n'avons nous n'avons pas les gars fin
mais on a quand même je suis bien placé
pour savoir dassault systèmes est un
leader mondial du logiciel industriel et
donc grâce aussi à cette capacité du
numérique en france et des ingénieurs
dans le domaine du numérique on a la
possibilité d'accélérer la compétitivité
de nos entreprises en france pourvu
qu'un forme d'accompagnement soient
faits dans l'innovation dans la baisse
des impôts est aussi une certaine revue
des problématiques sociales non pas pour
enlever des droits acquis mais pour
mieux gérer l'argent de l'état pour
sécuriser ces problématiques sociales on
trouvera bien qu'aujourd'hui seront une
des grandes préoccupations dans le cadre
du dialogue social des semaines et mois
à venir à ne pas lire une ag à un point
de vue
stratégique la guerre d'ukraine poser
problème de ravitaillement de
différentes
technologies et cetera est-ce que ça
pénalise l'industrie française
oui je crois que alors c'est moins la
guerre en ukraine que l'ensemble des
perturbations sur les chaînes
d'approvisionnement en prenant en compte
aussi la russie et dans un contexte où
par ailleurs au mois de mai 2000 22 40 %
du pipe chinois est bloqué par l'aco
vide donc l'empilement de ces
difficultés fait qu'aujourd'hui
l'approvisionnement et les chaînes
mondialisé de l'industrie sont beaucoup
plus complexes avec des coûts de
logistique et d'approvisionnement plus
élevé
ce n'est pas propre à l'industrie
française vous l'avez aussi aux états
unis vous l'avez chez nos voisins
européens mais clairement ses impacts
l'industrie française et européenne
alors comment on fait en raccourci les
chaînes de production et on investit
pour reconstruire des capacités de
production pas seulement ce qui a
longtemps été
un tropisme français de dire il faut
être à la pointe sur l'innovation la r&d
mais aussi d'avoir des sites de
production faut pas séparer les idées de
la production je voudrais vous faire
réagir sur très brièvement sur cette
question là en matière de gouvernance on
dit que la supériorité américaine est
liée à ce qu'ils aient une darpa c'est à
dire cette agence qui regroupe un peu
les compétences les crédits et caetera
et qui happe et qui permet de soutenir
toutes les actions est-ce qu'il faut une
darpa française pardonnez moi mais on
est limité par le temps une minute à
rêver guinée chacun l'organisme qui
aujourd'hui porte le plan france 2030 de
mon point de vue aurait vocation à se
muscler et à devenir cette fameuse darpa
en s'articulant avec tous les
investissements qui sont faits au niveau
militaire parce qu'il ya un travail
remarquable qui est fait au niveau
militaire et de commande publique et
d'innovation et d'accompagnement y
compris d'ailleurs
de futurs start up et on peut s'appuyer
sur ça en tout cas on en a les éléments
30 milliards d'euros sur france2 1030
c30 mignard budgétaire ce n'est pas du
prêt ce n'est pas de la garantie et on
n'a jamais eu en france depuis les
années 70 un plan aussi ambitieux pour
accompagner les nouvelles filières
technologiques alors darpa française
vous êtes favorable à ça c'était pas en
israël la darpa elle est américaine elle
restera américaine mais il faut
encourager l'innovation de rupture en
france parce qu'on a besoin à un moment
donné d'avoir des ruptures mais je le
répète pas contre ce qui fonctionne
aujourd'hui les avions de dassault il
vole très bien donc on va pas les clouer
au sol en disant on va faire de la
rupture ils ont ils sont très bien donc
il faut de l'innovation de rupture et en
parallèle soutenir ce qui marche et même
ce qu'ils veulent et vous darpa patrick
daher moi je suis un
tout petit peu d'appréhension
au niveau de la supply chain c'est au
niveau des outils et des pme les grands
organismes
inaccessible pour pour nos entreprises
je m'en méfie un tout petit peu et je
suis beaucoup plus favorable à des
opérations ciblées filière par filière
faut-il j'ai cité le corac tout à
l'heure il ya d'autres filières qui sont
organisées de la même façon faut-il en
dessus de ces filières mettre un
organisme d'état
peut-être mais à condition que ce ne
soit pas lui qui pilote il faut que le
pilotage des opérations se fasse le plus
près possible du terrain à mon avis
alors eric trappier ces innovations
disruptive ces innovations du futur est
ce qu'elles ont besoin d'être encadrés
planifié on parle beaucoup maintenant de
planification est ce que la une dar pas
française vous parait-elle
idoine pour mettre la france sur un plan
de développement très avancé elle n'a
pas réussi pour deux raisons
le budget colossal que les états unis
acceptent de mettre dans cette agence de
la capacité à l'échec ces terres pour
réussir il faut être capable aussi de
faire face à l'échec le darpa finances
sans projet peut-être cinq ans devront
venir
le le vaccin modern art où des belles
fusée ou les beaux avions mais d'autres
vont être mis de côté donc fois accepté
l'échec cette notion de l'échec
l'industrie n'est avec on a tous connu
des échecs dans votre carrière de
projets qu'on a été obligés de
redimensionner c'est pour ça que je dis
toujours qu'il faut toujours un plan b
l'état a un peu de mal sur l'échec parce
que l'état a des échéances qui sont pas
les mêmes mais des échéances électorales
nous on a des échéances de technologique
etc financière donc c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose donc je pense qu'il
faut gérer ça à deux niveaux les
industries de souveraineté doivent être
dans des souverains l'endroit des
agences françaises on peut mutualiser
ensemble d'efforts au niveau européen et
on doit le faire encore faut-il partager
les mêmes la même idée de la
souveraineté ce qui n'est pas toujours
le cas y compris avec nos voisins les
plus proches et donc c'est à ce prix
qu'on pourra mieux utiliser les deniers
publics pour aider et puis l'an dernier
parce qu'il faut un marché et ça c'est
aux industriels de trouver le marché
pour être capable d'investir et d'y
croire et de mettre les meilleurs sur
les sur ses développements qui
permettent de faire avancer la
technologie nerfs si monsieur trappier
alors écouter il me reste à vous
présenter une brève biographie pour en
finir avec le déclin de patrick artus et
marie-paule virard
publié chez odile jacob et sa part de
notre sujet des priorités économiques et
sociales en france et d un ouvrage aussi
sur la souveraineté industrielle d'elie
cohen qui parut également chez odile
jacob
alors ces vannes israël vous avez publié
un certain temps les études et la guerre
les normaliens dans la tourmente un mot
sur ce sujet qui est un peu mais alors
là on est on est un peu loin d'eux on
est un peu loin mais vous me ramener à
une vie un peu antérieurs dont
effectivement bon je me suis passionné
pour ce qui s'est passé pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale à l'école
normale supérieure et en fait il ya
beaucoup d'élèves qui ont eu un très bel
engagement dans la résistance il ya 10%
de résistants très actif et jusqu'à 20%
il ya des grands scientifiques étaient
dans les laboratoires de l'école normale
supérieure yves rocard le grand
physicien donc voilà il ya eu 2 il ya eu
des engagements il ya il ya un grand
physicien qui s'appelle jean claude
peker qui était membre du collège de
france qui a passé le concours avec
l'étoile johnny andré mandouze qui était
un grand un grand spécialiste de
philologie latine et qui s'est engagé
contre la guerre d'algérie et qui a
fondé les cahiers du témoignage chrétien
donc ça a été un peu une école de vie
que travailler sur cette période merci
maman pas dire une hache et vous avez un
livre conseillé non mais je peux citer
un livre coécrit avec elisabeth moreno
qui n'a rien à voir avec notre
conversation quoique femme ministre et
ses ministres qui est à la fois un
entretien un échange avec elisabeth
moreno qui a comme moi travailler dans
le monde privé et dans la technologie
s'agissant d'elle et qui a été ministre
et qui est aussi un plaidoyer pour les
filles et notamment un plaidoyer pour
les filles dans les métiers
scientifiques techniques ont veillé la
boucle est bouclée merci madame merci
mes yeux d'avoir participé à cette
émission j'espère qu'on aura l'occasion
d'en retraité passe est un sujet
prometteur et qui fait rêver notamment
pour les nouvelles générations
je voudrais remercier l'équipe de lcp et
vous laisser avec cette pensée de xavier
niel
l'ambition nourrie l'innovation vise est
grand car au pire ça marche
[Musique]